in the German city of all the house and
dozens waited in line at a mobile
testing center to be screened workers
from the fire department and Red Cross
taking samples from drivers in their
vehicles assigned directed people not to
leave their cars or open their windows
while waiting concern is growing in
Germany after a warning if people don't
heed social distancing measures 10
million people could be infected with
coronavirus within months and German
Chancellor Angela Merkel responded to
those fears in an address to the nation
telling people to listen and act names
it is serious take it seriously not
since German reunification no not since
World War two has there been such a
challenge to our country so much relies
on our universities solidarity Darwin
and Kampf in a sign of the economic
impact the virus is having across Europe
the Spanish government announced all
hotels will have to close down by
Tuesday the Foreign Office is telling
British travelers to contact their
Airlines and tour operators urgently to
try and get home finally get to flight
tomorrow
been a nightmare here seven days
standing on the balcony sitting on the
balcony and going to the supermarket
which is just behind me over the road
police patrolling the streets to take
you off the streets to see you order the
food shopping or going to a chemist in
France which introduced restrictions on
movements yesterday the army started
transferring critically ill patients to
a military facility to ease the pressure
on crowded hospitals in the
worst-affected east of the country
doctors have warned the system is at
breaking point with a shortage of
equipment and many health workers
themselves becoming ill and now Belgium
has followed the example of other
European nations in the capital Brussels
elderly were allowed to go into
supermarkets early before a lockdown in
the city people have been ordered to
stay at home as much as possible to only
go out for work to collect food and to
keep their distance the European Union
took the dramatic step this week of
agreeing to temporarily close its
borders to all non-essential travel from
other countries to try to stop the
spread of the virus but populations in
the EU will need to change their way of
living to help bring that about
Michelle Clifford Sky News Brussels